it is a field of impact business in
Brazil it is an emerging field it is in its
beginnings it has a lot to develop but I
think we could cite as
the main achievements to be achieved
in the short term The first is to bring the
government into this discussion if  approaching
the different government instances
Because most of the products and
services that are being
developed today by entrepreneurs
need to be sold or need to have
partnership relationships with
public equipment so, for example,
innovative technologies to improve the quality of
education that could be adopted in
public schools  or systems that
improve management and give more efficiency
to the public health system, so having
the government's participation is fundamental.
people
see more investment mechanisms for
more advanced businesses  designed but
innovative mechanisms that take into account the fact
that these businesses are different they
have their uniqueness they give return
in a longer term and that is why they
need specific mechanisms
and I think that a third
important aspect to be developed is that the
we can, in a very short term, be able to
present businesses that are really
consolidated cases of success, businesses
that have reached scale and that can
inspire other entrepreneurs and more
investors to come to this field and
help build more businesses in
Brazil.